stéphanie gibeau bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes lanceuse d'alert vous même
vous suivez on imagine de presse que
s'apprête à adopter le sénat cet après
midi là pour cette proposition de loi
qui vise à améliorer la protection des
lanceurs dallaire quelles en sont les
grandes lignes en quelques mots
est en fait la france n'avait pas de
loin de protection des citoyens ce qui
comme me paraît a priori un petit peu
délirant dans la mesure où on n'arrête
pas de répéter qu'on est le pays des
droits de l'homme et qu'on a une
constitution cela étant avec les
affaires qui se sont succédé ces quinze
dernières années des affaires donc qui
touche et à l'intérêt général des
affaires qui ont défrayé la chronique en
france en europe mais aussi partout dans
le monde la france avait fait passer
cette loin qui portait le nom de
l'ancien ministre des finances la loi
sapin 2 de lutte contre la corruption
dans laquelle il y avait un volet de
protection des lanceurs d'alerté
la france étant comme vous le savez un
des pays fondateurs de l'europe elle
avait finalement
fait en sorte que sa voix porte au
parlement européen pour qu'ils aient une
directive qui soit donc voté en 2019
donc une fois de plus à l'initiative de
la france et les 27 pays de l'europe
avaient jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 donc
c'est ce que mois dernier pour
retranscrire cette
directive européenne dans les textes
nationaux je crois que trois pays
seulement sur les vingt-sept on tue on
peut arriver à l'échéance du 31 décembre
2021 donc nous la france sommes en train
de faire passer ce texte de protection
des lanceurs d'alerté alors pour les
auditeurs qui ne savent pas ce que c'est
qu'un lanceur d'alert ce sont des
personnes souvent des salariés des
collaborateurs mais ça peut être aussi
des citoyens des dépliants des
des personnes en tout cas un physique
qui dénonce des dysfonctionnements des
fraudes qui touche à l'intérêt général
faibles ou d'ailleurs
alors c'est exactement ce que j'ai fait
moi en
2008 donc vous voyez ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure depuis 15 ans nos
dossiers finalement ont permis à la fois
à ce qu'ils aient un éveil des
consciences et justement à ce qui est
aussi une évolution de la société est
une évolution du droit on aura au moins
servi un simple panneau alerte et nos
vie foutue que dans l'air parce qu'il
faut quand même être très clair étant
donné les pressions qu'on a subi tout à
l'heure que vous avez présenté le sujet
vous avez dit ou des licenciements ou
des procédures ou des menaces etc s'est
passé et voilà un peu et vous estimez
qu'il y a des manques tout de même dans
cette proposition noix ou vous êtes
plutôt satisfaites
moi ce que je pense et cet avis n'engage
que moi c'est que la loi se focalise sur
le processus de la lettre est absolument
pas sûr
c'est pas une réponse si vous voulez aux
problèmes systémiques qu'on appuie qu'on
a pu démontrer pourquoi je me dis ça
c'est que le premier finalement à ne pas
respecter la loi ou à ne pas respecter
le droit c'est l'état j'ai vu moi dans
mon propre dossier puisque c'est tout en
train d'attaquer d'étain pour l'avoir et
désistement sur le fameux dossier qui
m'occupe depuis 15 ans mais en même
temps on peut aussi se demander à quoi
ont servi nos alertes puisque
effectivement d'un côté une vie ont été
foutu en l'air et que peut-être ce ces
lois vont aider à protéger les gens qui
vont oser se lever dans les années qui
viennent
cela étant ou est-ce qu'on en ait des
alertes qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a fait
nous sur un dossier d'évasion fiscale et
comme le dossier du ps avec la bande est
condamnée donc après pratiquement quinze
ans vous avez eu depuis les panama
papers les pandora paper des footballs x
les doubles et myspace malta files
donc vous voyez bien que c'est histoire
d'évasion fiscale par exemple on n'y a
pas touché on n'y rien faisait il ya
beaucoup de paroles il ya beaucoup
d'actes et puisqu'on a pu aussi réaliser
c'est que certains en sortent alertes
sont soutenus alors que d'autres sont
complètement abandonnés et dans la
foulée justement de cette loi de
protection des lanceurs dallaire les
médias parle beaucoup depuis deux mois
il ya eu beaucoup de bravo
d'associations syndicats
pour que les personnalités qui ont pris
la parole dans les médias mais n'est pas
que la même une semaine à l'assemblée
nationale
la protection finalement deux lanceurs
d'alert étrangers et qui en l'occurrence
vous pourrez être accueillis par le pays
qui se dit le pays des droits de l'homme
fait référence à julian assange à l'insu
de la nasa oui on a aussi le cas des
jeunes en 2013 qui demandent l'asile à
la france qui avait été refusé que donc
à la fois c'est complètement
contradictoire
c'est pas logique
on peut se demander aussi si c'est un
petit peu démagogique donc il faut être
quand même très très prudente donc ceux
qui voudraient lancer des alertes dans
les mois ou les années qui viennent pour
qu'il soit quand même très conscient que
tous à un moment donné ça passe par le
cadre de la loi et que la seule chose
qu'il faille retenir c'est d'être bien
entouré parce que lorsqu'une alerte
c'est un accident et ce qui arrive
derrière finalement ce sont des sur
accident et c'est ce qu'il faut éviter
donc il faut éviter d'être
comment dire influencé par la pression
par le stress qui pourrait
éventuellement faire des erreurs parce
qu on est juste des êtres humains à
lanceur dallaire c'est pas une machine
professionnelle c'est pas un métier
c'est pas quelque chose sur laquelle les
les citoyens ont une technicité donc il
faut être très vigilant et savoir très
bon centre merci beaucoup stéphanie
gibeau d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ce matin sur rtl franc je la rappelle
lanceuse d' alerte et auteur de la
traque des lanceurs dallaire